voilà c'est fait jacques chirac l'est la
place nouveau premier ministre de
françois mitterrand nommé en fin d'après
midi michel rocard on a remarqué le côté
chaleureux de cette passation de pouvoir
les deux hommes qui se tutoient se
connaissent depuis longtemps il était
condisciples à sciences po et à l'ena
bonsoir jacques chirac venait à peine de
quitter matignon que michel rocard
faisait sa première déclaration de
premier ministre je ne le pensais
qu'à tous ceux qui en france aujourd'hui
ont une inquiétude quelconque quelle que
soit la manière dont ils nous ont voté
pour leur avenir pour leur emploi pour
leur formation professionnelle pour leur
sécurité et ses stats tout cela que je
penserais pendant l'exercice de ses
fonctions
dès que possible naturel